come on stormy stop making such a big
deal about this everyone knows it's just
an act
I work in adult films we're not really
known for our acting I saw North and
South Korea why can't I serve us sorry
Donald it's too late for that I know you
don't believe in climate change but a
storm's a comin baby stormy Daniels
climate activists of course everything's
inevitable she was deeply traumatized by
her alleged relationship with the
president and 130 grand she got
afterwards so traumatized that she
decided to relive it on Saturday Night
Live on Saturday in case you missed it
but this point millions of dollars have
been spent investigating the stormy
Daniels story CNN has turned its entire
daytime schedule over to examining the
details of the story allegedly
investigators are on the hunt for a
crime but if there was a crime what was
it exactly and more the point who is the
victim of this crime which a good scene
as a lawyer he advised both of Hillary
Clinton's presidential campaigns and he
joins us tonight Richard thanks for
coming out here of course so I mean a
per requisite for a crime as a victim
right someone has to suffer because of
what happened you know for it to be a
crime who's the victim of this crime
well in terms of the criminal law the we
look it appears that what would you know
that the Trump campaign whether it's he
himself or Michael Cohen or somebody
else engaged in campaign finance
violations probably banking violations
right so when you basically make a
contribution the notion that this was
done to resolve a family issue is
preposterous this affair happened in
2006 to say and then though all these
women came out that would certainly
finish my thing
all these women came out of the woodwork
he admitted to grabbing people by the
genitals and to say that somehow only
then in a week or two before the
election that this was needed to spare
her you know Donald Trump's family the
trauma of having to open up to what
happened between him and stormy Daniels
it's preposterous
who's where's the victim here I mean no
it's sincere look the American public is
the victim so right here you have Donald
Trump accused of sleeping it didn't
conduct an affair even if every gal
occasions are true he slept with this
woman once she says so if that happened
of course and she got paid according to
her a hundred and thirty grand right for
that was kind of a lot you know for that
she is she the victim do you think yeah
she her lawyer going on television
aggrieved wouldn't that really be kind
of extortion though
well again the Vick sincere since your
question no it's not extortion together
on a voluntary basis and later one of
them says you know what in order not to
tell anybody about that you need to pay
me money what would that be called well
he's trying to enforce an agreement
which she says and her lawyer says is
not enforceable because he didn't sign
it right there's usually two parties
through a contract but before that well
agreement itself if I if you and I
engage in voluntary behavior together
let's likely drink a 12-pack we're not
supposed to and you say you know I'm
gonna tell people but that less you pay
me money and I do you're extorting me no
no sorting they they had a contract
which he didn't sign so they didn't have
a contract in fact the allegation is he
paid her money and apparently did
through his lawyer in order that she
wouldn't talk about this thing right she
says happen so hold on I just probably
assist sincere question I understand and
I know you're not allowed to ask this on
CNN because you know I guess I don't
know why meet you or something
but it's a real question yeah why is
that not extortion yeah so it's the
American public that was denied justice
here because had they known the facts
before the election you know what
somebody you know when these suburban
women who seem to be peeling away from
Donald Trump in real time because I want
to take what you're saying serious yes
I'm finding it the laughs right
describe the voter who voted for Trump
in November of 2016 who would have been
shocked to learn that he'd had a one-day
relationship with a pornographic actress
and paid her not to time one month after
his wife had given birth okay right and
then he paid one hundred thirty thousand
dollars to cover up I think even for
these suburban women who didn't like
Hillary who went to Donald Trump because
they were just willing to roll the dice
even for them and I think it's happening
in real time today that's a you know
there's a bridge so really so even after
like a hundred and fifteen Howard Stern
programs where he bragged about adultery
even after 35 years in the public eye
where his marriages disintegrated on the
front page of the New York Post even
after the Access Hollywood tape there
was someone out there or enough for them
to change the course the election who
would have been so stunned by this like
that doesn't sound good Trump I know are
you saying this seriously is this like
an elaborate joke
the suburban women weren't listening to
Howard Stern okay they were listening to
what Donald Trump was saying and he
denied it now who here in your audience
thinks that Donald Trump is telling the
truth is there a soul one person out
there who thinks he found the true me
had the accident see I'm I'm assuming
and I assume the second I heard it that
it was true because I always thought
that kind of to be a president a liar
what you're saying I'm assuming is that
people voted for Trump because the
people in charge had so mismanaged the
country yeah
wrecking the economy watching as the
middle class died getting us into
pointless wars that they wanted
something really different and they
voted for Trump despite his personal
you're saying you assume the president
States is a liar and I agree and the
concern is how will we know what he's
telling the truth about things that
matter now he's lying about what here's
what he was telling the truth when he
said the people in charge and I would
include Jeb Bush and everybody in the
Democratic field are complicit in
wrecking the country and we want
something new that's what the election
was about did you miss that paper and I
think the next election will be do you
want your child to grow up to be like
Donald Trump that's what the next
election is going to be about you've
asked me that question over and over or
that's what it's going to be about or
Eric Schneiderman who were going to talk
about next let's do yeah he's not
president I hope we give into the cast
the first stone contest that'll be
amusing richer thank you my pleasure
great to see her